today we're going to be talking about
mapreduce which is kind of a programming
paradigm for
doing large-scale computations across
a computing cluster
google originally came up with the whole
mapreduce idea and um
yeah that way of thinking about doing
large scale computations
and then it got popularized through an
open source implementation
called apache hadoop and then that
was then quite popular um in kind of
processing these very large volumes of
data so we can do an example of a
mapreduce computation so the first thing
with mapreduce is that your the job you
want to do has got to be able to be
split down into a map stage in a reduced
phase so the map phase
needs to be you want to do the same
computation across all your data items
at the same time
and so you do that all your data is
distributed across the cluster
now stored on the different nodes and
each node does the computation on its
own data
and then
the reduced stage would then take the
results of the map phase reduce it down
into kind of a single value and then
send that back as the result to the
computation a classic example would be
a word count so say we've got a massive
text file and we've got it in a
distributed file system across a cluster
and that means that each node of the
cluster will be doing the computation on
its own data and we want to count the
number of occurrences of each word in
that text well so for simplicity's sake
we've got a file which first line is aba
and then abc and then cd and this would
be distributed so let's say aba is on
the first node abc is on the second node
and then cd on the last node so the map
stage would take this and it would put
this into what's called a key value pair
so we're going to take each word as the
key so for each word within this we'll
map it so that the word's the key and
then we put the number one next to it is
the value we go a1 b1 a1 a1 b1 c1 and
then c1
d1 at the end of the map stage which is
here we've got all the keys and values
what happens then is a shuffle phase
which the programmer doesn't need to
know about it just kind of happens
in between and that basically groups
these on nodes based on the key so that
all data items with the same key are
stored in the same node we'll go to a1
and then on the second node we'll have b
one one and on the last node we might
have c one one and d one and the reduced
phase is going to return a single value
for each one of these keys so it's about
combining all of the values associated
with that key into one single value so
for this we want to count the number of
occurrences of
like the word a and so we're going to
reduce it
down and we're just going to use a plus
operator to do that in the reduce
function so
it then finally comes to a3 b2 c2 and d1
and if you imagine that we're doing this
on huge huge volumes of data so over
very very large files this kind of
computation is a lot more efficient if
you can distribute that because doing
this map phase of saying okay this is
one occurrence of the letter a that's
independent of anything else and so you
can split that across individual nodes
they can do that part of the computation
individually and then later on we do the
shuffle and reduce it all back to the
single value so are they physically
moving data or just moving the
computation saying right you're
responsible for that computation
um
they'll be moving the data this all
happens in one node this happens in one
node and then this bit would be in one
node because you'd need to know the key
and then all the values that are
associated with it in order to to do
that computation because the other point
about mapreduce is data locality so
doing the computation
close to where the data is stored so you
want to minimize the amount you're
moving data around
um because that obviously takes time so
you want to
move data around the cluster as little
as possible and do the computations
close to where it's stored so that is
the end of the mapreduce process yeah
you've done the reduce that's it what
you then do with that data is up to you
so
in like a business use case you could be
using it to go over you know millions of
customer records and get some
kind of statistics out of it
um you could then save that back to the
distributed file system
which is probably what they'd want to do
for later use
uh yeah after that stage it's up to your
use case is this still used
and so it would still be used in some
cases because this is very good for kind
of doing it like a single batch job
you've got one computation you want to
do over the data and get a single result
out of it
but then it's not a very flexible way of
doing it
so for example
you've got to be able to fit your
computation into this map stage in this
reduced space and you've got to be
working with key value pairs and this is
in the apache hadoop version anyway it
can be quite painful to put something
into that framework or just
too difficult to do
and then secondly
because this does basically get the data
do map do the reduce and then it just
writes it back to disk it's not very
good at reusing that same data across
multiple computations because you're
constantly having to write stuff back to
disk reload it
so it's not good for like iterative
algorithms
so a lot of data mining stuff such as
k-means clustering that would be going
over the data again and again and again
which mapreduce is not very good for
um so then this there are then
more recent big data processing
frameworks such as apache spark um that
are kind of designed to alleviate those
issues having a massive file of text or
anything and then having to move bits of
it around that feels like it's a bit
clunky as well is that the case as well
do you think having the distributed file
you'd use a distributed file system so a
lot of this would be
sorted out for you um so for example the
hadoop distributed file system
if you have like a huge file it's like
terabytes then it kind of splits it up
into chunks and puts single chunks on
like individual nodes in your cluster
then when you're doing the processing
kind of the point of these frameworks is
that you don't have to think about it
so that bits kind of hidden from the
programmer so for example in mapreduce
the programmer doesn't have to worry too
much about the shuffle phase so that's
done automatically they just have to do
the map and the reduce you don't want to
be moving data around is the point
because that's taking up time you want
to be keeping everything local on a
single node as much as possible
train for a long time and let's not let
steve off a hook right there steve over
here high value of two high value of one
whatever that means the interesting
thing about this is we're not performing
a classification little endian systems
so that's why we call it endianness it
all traces back to